deutschland das land der dichter und
denker das land mit einer global
führenden automobilindustrie das land
mit einem gesundheitssystem das weltweit
seinesgleichen sucht und auch das land
in dem mütter nichts wert sind
so sieht das zumindest die
hauptdarstellerin des videos dass wir
uns heute anschauen und zwar wenn wir
uns ein video von die strengsten eltern
der welt anschauen da dreht sich alles
um all die 14 jährige lilly aus bochum
die wie auch sonst alle kinder bei die
strengsten eltern der welt einen
kapitalen dachschaden hat von woraus
genau der besteht das werk sie sind faul
und verschämt und verwöhnt immer mehr
teenager tanzen ihren eltern auf der
nase herum
ja okay an der stelle connector stopp
machen leute
ich rechne das muss ja sagen wieder mit
dem typischen verhalten was kinder oder
teenager die strengsten eltern der welt
an den tag legen und zwar dass sie einen
auf gangster machen und mit ihrem
taschengeld literally mit ihrem
taschengeld kaufen sie sich dann kippen
oder irgendwas und wenn ihre eltern und
sagen so er den leser was ist los mit
dir warum kaufst von einem taschengeld
kippen hat acht dann sind die mama du
kannst dich mal täglich das mir gar
nichts sagen von dir
bochum hier lebt die 13-jährige punkerin
lilly redding okay leute also ganz
normal kurz bevor wir jetzt überhaupt
anfangen noch irgendwas von ihr zu sehen
sie ist 13 zum ersten mal vor augen
halten sie ist 13 wenn ich mir vorstelle
was ich mit 13 gemacht habe oder wenn
ihr bisschen älter seid euch vorstellt
was mit 13 gemacht hat dann haben wir
sagen wir mal ein bisschen übertrieben
gesagt haben in windeln geschissen ok
andere leute sind ja immer mit 13
kettenraucher und beleidigen gewitter
200a rauchen saufen schulisch menschen
das ist ihr leben ihre aggressionen ihre
schlechte laune und ihren frust lässt
lilli am liebsten an ihrer mutter ab es
gibt zwei gold gerade kurzen winkel die
kommentare geschossen liga wo mein gott
der top kommentar zerstört sie komplett
es ist wirklich nicht mehr noch dass ich
weiß ich weiß nicht ob das so rein
menschen rechtlich erlaubt ist und
deutschlands wollen kommentar zu
schreiben
von dann viel 192 litti ist ein
komischer name in fetten auf 1000 juden
ehre genommen an der stelle mir ganz
wichtig zu sagen damit youtube mich da
nicht falsch versteht und dieses video
nicht irgendwie sperrt oder so es ist
selbstverständlich eine sehr sehr
schlechte idee und es hat immer davon
abgeraten werden als minderjährige
person substanzen zu konsumieren die
nach dem gesetz illegal feind sind nun
mit ist
brauchst du schon wieder dass es nicht
wieder nur noch gesagt kann auf meinem
zimmer
da könnte ich eigentlich schon wieder
verabschieden teilt euch mal vor augen
leute der punkt an dem die einkommen
sind sind an dem punkt angekommen dass
die mutter jetzt stress mit ihrer
tochter hat weil die 13-jährige tochter
nicht im zimmer rauchen sollte das wird
den kampf schon heute aufgegeben dass
sie ihre 13-jährige tochter rauchen
lässt
nur hätte ich im zimmer stelle ich mir
vor als person oder als instanz die
andere leute zu kontrollieren muss
einfach so weit die kontrolle verloren
das hier so was so weit einschränken
müsste das wäre so als würde deutschland
sagen so der junge liebe bürgerinnen in
deutschland keine morde zwischen 22 uhr
und 8 uhr morgens wird da wir wirklich
alle gehirnzellen
es gibt nicht ein leckeres als geld von
seinen eigenen eltern zu nehmen ja
taschengeld zu nehmen in dem haus zu
bundes daher in eltern bezahlen und dann
zu sagen aber mein zimmer so irgendwo
schon aber letzten endes zahlen deine
eltern die das wo hast du das geld
wieder die kippen
juli 14 sieht nicht so heute würde sie
arbeiten gehen also
was willst du machen mir meine gesamte
existenzgrundlage nehmen indem du mich
aus dem haus raus wirst und mein
taschengeld wegnimmt
das würde tatsächlich funktionieren
fragt dann hätte ich ja dann könnte ich
ja hat ich habe dem taschengeld mehr von
dem ich meinen banker lifestyle bezahlen
können um eine kippen
die mutter sag mal 13 jahre alt so als
ob wir jetzt debattieren wir jetzt hier
auch und nicht es wird es klar zu sagen
das kommt doppelt schön war es war
wirklich in dieser situation nicht nötig
sie hat jetzt ihrer mutter hat binnen
einer minute höchstens zwei minuten
mehrmals den tod gewünscht aber mit der
aufforderung geh sterben
ihr gegenüber getreten hat und dann ist
die situation geklärt
sie hat sich schon wirklich wie das
allergrößte parkverhalten mit gebraucht
mit taschengeld kippen und lässt sich
von der mutter nichts sagen okay und
dann geht die mutter aus dem zimmer raus
und dann schiebt sie noch mal so auf
unnötig so ein [ __ ] hinterher
kleine hof so ist es nämlich stört mich
noch viel weniger
während ich in den klamotten die meine
mutter mir bezahlt hat mit den
rastalocken und perlen in den
rastalocken die meine mutter mir bezahlt
hat auf der couch auf dem bett sitze
dass meine mutter wird zweiter und mit
dem laptop im internet surfen den meine
mutter bezahlt hat panka lifestyle der
punk ist ja vollkommen unabhängig quasi
ich habe mir eine hoffen dass sie diese
bilder später mal sieht und ich kann mir
ganz gut vorstellen dass es tatsächlich
auch so ist und dann im nachhinein sich
richtig krass dafür schämt safe also ich
will auch gar nicht den heiligen
spielleute ich habe auch viel steigert
meine eigene steuer und ich habe mit
sicherheit auch dinge gesagt mein ding
kamerateam gefilmt hätte dann würde ich
jetzt auch nicht gut dasteht so ist es
nicht aber ich warne ich habe diesen
level hätte ich einfach mal zu hause mit
der kippe auf welt gesetzt hätte gesagt
so wird mit zwölf somalier sterben
die ihr euch mehr so gefasst worden
also da ist auch immer bei solchen
extremfällen würde ich fast immer sagen
wenn wir jetzt mal wieder auf einer
ernsten ebenen sind ist immer auch die
eltern sind natürlich auch mit schulze
also kannst ein kind auch nur so viel
schuld und verantwortung für das eigene
handeln geben
also man kann sicher in den allermeisten
fällen davon ausgehen dass die eltern da
auch nicht ganz schuld das würde mich
tatsächlich würde ich sogar glauben ich
kann mir vorstellen wie diese in ihrem
zimmer schild so tapete
anders haben morgen wege ein komplettes
zimmer fällt fast auseinander um sie
zumindest schon das könnte mir das
vorstellen problem wiederum soll wir
nicht erfreut aber wie du bist
14 also das kann man nicht sagen guck
mal die hat sie ernsthaft hinten sind so
eine leere flasche oettinger ins regal
gestellter leere bierflasche
das kann doch nicht ernst nehmen musst
du bist innerlich so ein bisschen aus
dem ganzen dinge zum schellen ausweichen
die ich von meinen eltern für die
sprüche bekommen hätte berechtigt dass
man merkt allerdings auch das hat ihm
schon gesagt habe die mutter kann sich
überhaupt nicht ich jetzt also wirklich
mal sieben oder so
sie sagt so neu in die top 12 und dann
was macht sie so hat es irgendwelche
konsequenzen wenn die tochter so frech
hier ist nein sie lässt sich sogar
darauf ein also wie gesagt dass da ist
auch ein fehler
eine trostlose wohnsiedlung in berlin
stanislav bitte ich regelmäßig das ist
das wird schon wieder
und ich garantiere ich gebe ich euch
brief und siegel drauf dass die ganzen
jugendlichen kinder die da jetzt
mitgemacht haben by the way wer kommt
auf die idee damit zu machen sich so
krass stehen werden demnach handy werden
so krass können sie wenn sie das sehen
wir ja was war das jetzt bei ihm hat er
kurz der satan kontrolle übernommen
eine trostlose wohnsiedlung in berlin
stanislav klasse klassiker leute wenn
mal wieder zwei grad am 10
hier sollte ich irgendwie komisch ist
getränk rainer denke einfach kurz per
per teamviewer klingt sich auf einmal
der satan so in eurem körper rein ist wo
kann ich kurz ein körper wahrnehmen es
weißt du bist gerade chillen
bis gerade am siepen lass mich trotzdem
kurz mal hier rein ich sehe jetzt kein
kabel eins da wollte ich mal kurz noch
mal zeigen dass ich da bin
metal musik computerspiele stanislav
lebt in einer virtuellen parallelwelt zu
der seine mutter keinen zugang hat ja ok
aber er ist schon wieder bisschen älter
und er wirkt wirklich so ein bisschen
missverstanden auf mich eher leute so
die erzählerstimme steht ist es so dass
computerspiele elemente so ok und wo ist
das problem
also leute ich hoffe dass sie die
strengsten eltern der welt videos neben
lachen und wünschen euch auch so ein
bisschen ein bisschen wertschätzung
vielleicht auch für die eigenen eltern
geben und so ein bisschen auch dafür
dass man auch ein bisschen dankbar dafür
zeigen dass die eigenen eltern sofern
machen dass zumindest meine sicher
schreibt mir gerne in die kommentare was
ihr von lilly 14 und 13 zeitgleich
haltet es gibt einfach folgen kann aber
von der stadt ausmacht es gut